i'm smiling so big it's ridiculous we're
back with henry winkler and one of our
show's favorite correspondents
jonah larson who will be giving a full
review on henry's
35th children's book
life camera danger book number two in
the alien superstar series
and it's time for in the loop with jonah
jonah is an incredible avid reader
um and one of our biggest connections is
books
so we thought how perfect if henry you
would allow
us to have jonah review your book
i would be honored i i just want to say
jonah first of all nice to meet you
and second of all i am amazed by your
hands
constantly working on a piece of art
well i'm so excited to meet you mr
winkler
and i have two main big points about
alien superstar
number two lights camera danger the
first one
is that it was so funny i'm usually a
serious person i read
encyclopedias autobiographies and many
other things
and i've never laughed out loud while
reading a book
but i'm here to say proudly that alien
superstar number two
was the first book that made me laugh
out loud and
my parents were just looking at me so
confused why i kept on several occasions
laughing out loud
so i wanted to thank you for giving me
an escape and a way to just
get away from all the bad things going
on and number two
it had so many parallels to my life and
what i think
is the life of so many others out there
and how
you need to accept yourself as you are
and
have others accept you as the way you
are and that is why i thank you so much
for writing this book from me and for
all the other kids
internationally okay so let me just say
first of all thank you that might be one
of the greatest reviews
uh that lynn oliver and i have ever
gotten
in the entire time we've been writing
since 2002
you're so perceptive jonah um because
you know i
what i realized we write books about the
kid
me and you who are on the outside
looking in thinking how are we going to
get in there
how are we going to get inside to the
whatever that crowd is and then you said
it
we don't need to you just be yourself
and being yourself is authentic
and authentic is cool i totally agree
and we stabbed since this book was the
first book that i've
maybe laughed out loud i'm here to
proudly give alien superstar number two
lights camera danger five out of five
crochet loops oh my god
oh my god i'm so excited jonah
jonah before we go is there anything
else you would like to ask henry
i've been holding this inside ever since
i started your book
which was more fulfilling being an actor
or writing children's books hands down
writing a book now i've dreamt of being
an actor since i was seven
but the fact that my name is on a book
that there are books that make you
laugh that is the proudest outside my
family
the proudest moment of my life thank you
so much moving on to the second one
at the end of alien superstar number two
there were some hints that there was
going to be a third book
can you let us sit on a little secret
fingers crossed
we are in the middle of writing the
third book
as we speak when it's done i'm so
excited i'm sending you a copy
thank you that means a lot jonah what
you
said made me feel i i
i don't have words it was just
unbelievably
thoughtful and gracious and i thank you
thank you very much i felt the same way
when we were reading your book
and goodbye drew and goodbye mr winkler
and crochet away your friends
crochet away everyone thank you jonah
and henry
light's camera danger book number two in
the alien superstar series
is available now